c'est en fait une fanfare de cavalerie
qui rassemble uniquement des anciens
musiciens de la fanfare du 500 Yem
régiment de Charles de combat en
garnison à Rambouillet jusqu'en 1994 en
fait date de dissolution de la fanfare
donc l'an dernier on a recréé voilà
cette association pour essayer de
refaire jouer tous les anciens musiciens
qui sont passés qui sont passés donc au
régiment dans ces années-là
[Musique]
on a recherché donc l'adjoint donc
Thierry berger de l'époque on l'a
retrouvé on lui a exposé notre projet il
nous a dit ok vous êtes combien on est
30 mais il y a que 10 musiciens il y a
la fanfare c'était 45 musiciens à
l'époque il dit bah faut continuer à
chercher mais je vous suis à 200% et
donc on a cherché et aujourd'hui on a
retrouvé 183 anciens musiciens donc qui
sont passés donc de 73 à 94 dernière
année et on est encore à peu près une
bonne soixantaine à jouer
[Musique]
de son des morceaux
forcément militaires très connu la
musique militaire mais pas que c'était
la particularité justement de cette
fanfare du 50e régiment Charles de
combat où on jouait aussi des morceaux
un peu exotiques on s'était assez
nouveau dans le milieu militaire et
c'était une major Souplet qui avait
apporté ce renouveau de la musique on va
jouer des morceaux je vais vous dire
citer par exemple trompette latino
trompette Chacha voilà ce sont et qui
étaient joués à l'époque lors de
représentation on faisait pas que du
militaire
[Musique]